It was just a crazy idea.
I was sitting on a plane and it was dark outside
and I was thinking crazy.
If I were a vampire, I had to get myself a ticket for a night flight
and when this gets hijacked, I have a serious problem.
When I write the story, I'm just thinking,
"Okay, what do I think is cool?
What do I like?"
I was thinking maybe we should do it much more emotional,
and then I came up with the idea that
she is not alone on the board.
She has a little boy.
So we added this to the story
and this is what really makes it special.
I think it's easy to connect with her because she's a mother
and there's the son.
I think even if you don't have children of your own,
I think this is something everyone can relate to.
We have the framed story,
the movie begins with the end.
First she definitely is the main character, but switches to the boy.
I never believed that Blood Red Sky was just working in Germany,
so it shouldn't be a German movie.
And I had the idea what can be more international
than a transatlantic flight.
When it comes to writing, I cannot stop it.
I think it can be quite frustrating for all the people around me,
especially my wife and my son.
When it flows and you have an idea it's great,
but it can also be very very frustrating if you get
writers block and don't know how to go on.
The most difficult part was doing this action sequences because
it takes place in a very contained environment.
How can we do it?
Because our main guy is over here in the front of the plane
and the other one is at the back of the plane,
and it was like playing chess.
Thank you very much.